I was this thing you do with Joey Diaz I
didn't see that go back that yeah
Oh with Joey Diaz yeah I'll go to the
video chip it's a show for complex and
goalie alpha you go hurry my garlic
shrimp I will can go back there and do
the 10 years because they came straight
from the moms of classic I got a story
for you that song hey soos Trejo's my
boys a new show on first we feast grant
likes tacos Condor good guy man the best
I like that girl on the road together
was a great comic cousin special on
Showtime he's the best
yep the tram yeah he was great dude Joe
his story how he farted when he was in
line at the DMV oh I was laughing so
hard he said there's some Russian guy
behind him he put a tweet on it and I go
dude you tweeted Solaris they told me
the story so he was sitting in like a
DMV interstate he's there for like two
hours he was he was in heels and I
[ __ ] got garlic that night and he was
a garlic the night before he was I'm
[ __ ] sitting in line he says my full
name is I'm sitting in line Brendan chop
because I'm sitting there I got a fart
and I can feel it all night it's been
said I didn't feel like Tata garlic news
there's a Russian behind me I thought
[ __ ] it knows I fart is one of those
thick thick fog parts
thick going to is that Russian that is
in [ __ ] Chernobyl the line a mover
for Albert's to the sadness because he
is we sat in this fart [ __ ] the [ __ ]
next person I won't give the job away
but he talks about farting our plane oh
my god I was dying
really oh my goood oh I'll tell you joy
because they use that restaurant others
[ __ ] Shinobu
Nick I don't want to give it away cut
itself uh get funny
oh no you know I know because I tie a
party I am gonna call just clog vo
because I embody the hold on so how is
this it smell just kung fu going for
what you're saying
oomph well that's how it's said so as
I'm from I studied in China first on